so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your interim host car
Smallwood and today we're talking about
the dler brothers the family few that
created two sportsware empires this
video is based on an original article by
Ben Adelman if they provideed Social
Links for us they will be link below but
let's get to
it you can choose your friends but you
can't choose your family anyone who's
ever had a difficult relationship with a
sibling can attest to the truth
of that statement even the closest of
Brothers have moments that make them
wish they've been born an only child
after all someone with two brothers and
a sister I get it Thea brothers were to
it not the closest of siblings they
hated each other so much that they
refused to speak to each other but what
makes the feud between the dael brothers
so unique is that it spilled over from
their personal lives into their
professional ones they split the family
shoe making business off into two
separate companies that will come to
dominate the athletic wear business in a
way no one ever had before and there's
success of their respective companies
can at least in part be credited to the
Rivalry between the two brothers as they
push their employees to outdo each other
as a worldwide audience watched the feud
split apart not just the dler family but
their entire Hometown as well as every
other family who was forced to pick aide
the two companies are still household
names today each earning billions
annually in sales still competing
against one another for their own market
share forever lot together for the
personal rivalry of their Founders two
men two brothers who though they were
unable to shoot their family surely
which they could have
done and I'm just going to apologize now
for my pronunciation of any German words
or names um I'm hoping I've got the dla
one correctly but this next one is a
doozy heren garak was a typical of a
small Bavarian town in return in the
20th century kind of place with a very
long but altogether rather un
interesting history the perfect place
where a German man of modest means could
raise a family the at least that's what
Kristoff dasler must have thought he was
a Shoemaker a respectable profession in
a town that was known in the region for
its many cobblers and its small to
mediumsized shoe factories Kristoff and
his wife Paulie would raise their four
children in I'm going to try again the
heran ARA including Rudolph born in 1898
and Adolf born in 1990 Rudolph known as
Rudy initially worked side by side of
his father at the Shoe Factory until the
start of World War I when he joined the
army and served for the duration Adolf
known as Adi
and that's how I'm going to be referring
to him for the rest of the video for
obvious reasons was too young to join
the military at the start of the war and
he was instead an apprentice to a baker
before being scripted in 1918 when the
dler brothers returned home they found
their country had being devastated by
the war both economically and physically
while Rudy trained as a policeman Addy
an avid athlete had an idea for a
business that would combine his love of
sports with his family's knowledge of
shoe making at the time most athletes
wore ordinary shoes while competing
sometimes making modifications such as
hammering in Nails called spikes into
the sols to increase traction on grass
or dirt surfaces I did believe that if
he could could develop footware that was
specifically designed for athletic
competition it would increase the
performance of the athletes who wore
them a radical idea at the time when
Addy dasler first began making shoes in
1920 Germany was still experiencing
shortages of nearly enough every kind of
raw manufacturing material available as
well as money to purchase it so ADI
scavenged discarded military equipment
and repurposed it to make his as he
would later say sport shoes without
electricity Addy designed a leather
milling machine powered by a stationary
bicycle which various family members and
dla's first employees man to make the
first completed products ADI sent
samples of his shoes to sports teams
often demonstrating their effectiveness
by testing them himself as business
began to pick up steam Addie bought his
older brother into it together they
established the and again I apologize
for any poor pronunciation here the Juda
Dash shoe fabri which translates to the
dasler brothers Shoe Factory in 1924
initially it was a perfect partnership
Rudy was the outgoing face of the
business handling sales and marketing
while Addie was the quiet behind the
scenes presence who managed the
technical design and Manufacturing
process the ders became Pioneers in a
new discipline Sport Marketing ADI would
travel to the 1928 and 1932 Summer
Olympics offering his shoes for free to
interested athletes particularly those
participating in track and field events
when those athletes won medals while
wearing dla shoes setting world and
Olympic records in the process it
demonstrated the effectiveness of their
product to the world which in turn led
to more sales had world events turned
out differently it's possible the
partnership would have lasted for life
but it was not meant to
be in 1933 Hitler and the Nazi party
took power in Germany which changed the
country and eventually the world forever
both dler brothers joined the Nazi party
after the regime change both would later
claim after the war for obvious reasons
that they had felt pressur to join
because it seemed like the only way to
stay in business in the fascist L
country of the two Rudy was said to be
the more enthusiastic NY Addy apparently
confined himself to sports related
activities like coaching Hitler you
sponsor sports teams Addie at least
didn't appear to be much of a believer
in the National Socialist ideology best
demonstrated during the 1936 Olympics
held in Berlin before the games open
Addy traveled to the Olympic Village and
sought out star American athlete Jesse
Owens yes that Jesse Owens offering up
his newly designed track shoe for Owens
to wear Owens would go on to dominate
the games winning four gold medals and
in the process undermining Hitler's
ideology of a eared racial superiority
in front of the entire world and Hitler
himself is believed to be the first
sponsorship of any kind offered to an
African-American athlete by the time
World War II began in 1939 the dlers
were selling a report of 200,000 pairs
of shoes per year the war threaten
everything they built up to this point
Not only would the brothers be
conscripted into the army but civilian
manufacturing of all kinds was severely
curtailed and then shuttered completely
by the Nazi war machine as the entire
country was transformed into a total war
economy instead of making shoes the dler
factory was instead assigned to assemble
the Panza Shrek a German copy of the
American bazooka anti-tank weapon the
war also perly poisoned the two brothers
against one another tensions between
Addy and Rudy had existed since the mid
1930s which Rudy blamed on Addy's wife
Kathy who had her own chili relationship
with fredel Rudy's wife which Addy
blamed on Rudy's insistance that he
could run the family business better
than addi could and no one is really
quite sure about the origins of this
brotherly dispute whether it was
business or personal or a mix of both
but the Grim wartime conditions
certainly made things worse at the time
both brothers their wives and their
children all still lived together at a
family home with their parents which
would put strain on familiar relations
at the best of times wartime rationing
the threat of Ally bombing rat and the
threat and loss of their business pushed
both dlers to the breaking point
eventually things reached a point of no
return and Addy and Rudy became bitter
enemies instead of Partners and brothers
both suspected the other of using their
influence to have the other drafted
allowing them to take over the factory
correspondence between the pair became
increasingly acrimonious and at the end
of the war rather as an opportunity to
make amends it only intensified the
bitter dispute as members of a Nazi
party both dlers were required by the
occupying Americans to go before a den
nification panel to determine if they
committed any crimes or if they'
actively participated in any of the many
atrocities committed by the Nazis while
they were in power during the course of
these hearings both Rudy and ADI accused
each other of being more deeply involved
in the Nazi war machine than they had
admitted ADI accused Rudy of being a
member of the gestapo and Rudy accused
add in turn of being a war propheter
each presumably hoped that the Americans
would imprison the other allowing them
to take control of the business for
themselves eventually the authorities
release both brothers without charging
them but by then the damage was done
also awkward can we can we say that in
1948 the dler brothers decided to go
their separate ways the company's assets
were split evenly between them and the
firm's employees R allow to decide for
themselves which brother they wanted to
work for like the children of a divorced
couple deciding which one they wanted to
live with Once their partnership was
formally dissolved Rudy and adid dasler
never spoke to each other ever again
despite living for many years in the
same town only a few miles from one
another in the wake of the split each
brother found his own shoe company Addy
dasler took his nickname Addy and
combined it with the first three letters
of his last name to call his company
Adidas this why I have to address um any
Americans who confused my pronunciation
um Adidas the company has released an
official pronunciation guide for Adidas
and it is pronounced Adidas not Adidas
as some Americans think Rudy initially
tried doing the same thing naming his
company Ruda but the name didn't stick
and it was changed soon after to Puma
the Incan word for the American big cat
species sometimes known as a cougar on
mountain lion initially both companies
faced the same issue they'd faced in the
aftermath of the first war a ruined
German economy and shortages of
everything including manufacturing
materials this time however they were
helped by the American government which
was interested in rebuilding the economy
of Western Europe and provided both cash
and raw materials as part of legislation
like the Marshall Plan Adidas in
particular benefited greatly from close
cooperation with the Americans local
officers in charge of the occupation
knew Addy personally because of the dler
home had been requisition for use as
their quarters supposedly the only
reason the Americans hadn't blown up the
dla factory when they first had
occupying the town was because they
recognized the name dler as providing
shoes to Jesse Owens during the Olympics
their Factory was literally saved by a
shoe Adidas and pummer set up shop on
opposite sides of the town and what had
to this point being a personal Feud now
became a full-blown business rivalry as
both companies sought outd do one
another both companies developed
distinctive Styles adid asers three
stripes not only became their signature
look but also the company's logo why
puma in addition to the leaping cat logo
also developed the form strip which
initially just a piece of leather
reinforcement added to their shoes that
later became a distinctive style in of
itself and personally I'm an added ass
boy your boy is rocking his added asses
this is just my these are my gym clothes
the feud between the dlers not only
divided the entire dler family their
mother Pauline started with Rudy while
their sister Marie side with Addie but
also the entire town the two Sho
companies quickly became the largest
employers in the area and almost every
family in town had a member working for
one or the other but rarely both Adidas
people and Puma people did not associate
with one another they patronized
separate businesses were members of
different clubs and they never
intermarried even the town's two
football clubs were split along these
lines with one sponsored by Adidas and
the other by Puma the rest of West
Germany eventually took to calling the
town the town of bent next because the
first thing residents did upon meeting
someone new was look down to check which
shoes they were wearing like you might
very well have gotten a what are those
in German utter during this
time
the war between Adidas and pummer
spilled over onto the world stage
beginning in the 1950s both dlers
recognized the effectiveness of
sponsoring top athletes in regards to
the increased sales that would result
from the public and the two most popular
and widely viewed sporting events in the
world the FIFA World Cup and the
Olympics became their biggest
Battlegrounds initially the West German
national football team had been
sponsored by Puma but switch Brands to
Adidas after a falling out between Rudy
dasler and German coach sep Herberger
during the 1954 World Cup the first to
be televised adid dasler became a
national hero after the West Germans
triumphed over the heavily favored
Hungary in the final all the Germans
were wearing football boots that have
been custom designed by dler himself to
have detachable cleats that could be
adjusted by hand which gave the Germans
the distinct Advantage during the muddy
conditions on field that day the modern
football boot had been born the Olympics
proved to be a trickier Beast to tame in
those days the Olympics were a strictly
amateur event professional athletes were
barred from participating even accepting
something as simple as as a pair of free
running shoes in theory could lead to an
athlete being disqualified by the
international Olympic Committee or ioc
as a result both Adidas and Puma had to
resort to shall we say clandestine
methods to get their shoes onto the
feets of various athletes occasionally
this did back fire as is the case of
Armen Harry a German track athlete who
pumer reportedly paid Harry under the
table to wear their shoes in the 1960
Olympics after initially seeking payment
from Adidas which was refused after
winning the gold medal in the 100 meter
dash while wearing pumers it was a shock
to both companies when Harry appeared on
the metal stand wearing Adidas shoes
instead Harry had hoped to take
advantage of the Rivalry between the two
companies to collect money from them
both but it had the exact opposite
effect neither company wanted anything
to do with them anymore and he got
nothing from either the Rivalry ended up
being a boom to the sporting world as
the two companies spurred countless
Innovations in the field of sports where
as each dler brother saw a Performance
Edge by developing increasingly
sophisticated footware for athletes on a
positive note the Rivalry between the
two companies did end up spearing
countless Innovations in the field of
sportsware as each dler brother saw a
Performance Edge by developing
increasingly sophisticated footware for
athletes they sponsored Adidas and Puma
branched out into more and more Sports
developing specially made shoes for
baseball basketball grid iron football
Golf and More both companies also
expanded their products to lines outside
of shoes and other sports wear including
swimwear t-shirts athletic shorts
jerseys underwear etc etc well their
most lucrative expansion by far was into
the world of nonathletic specific sports
wear as sneakers became the world's most
popular shoe starting in the
1960s
y as Addie and Rudy dler Grew Older
their sons began to assume larger and
more prominent roles in their respective
businesses the introduction of horse
dler at Adidas and arming dler at Puma
might have provided an opportunity to
Thor the longstanding feud that had
divided up the family and the town but
both of them had their own ideas of how
how to expand their respective
businesses which would bring them into
conflict and bring the feud to an
entirely New Generation in the run up to
the 1970s World Cup in Mexico All Eyes
run the Brazilian team and indeed their
star player Pelle who was the world's
most famous athlete at the time years
earlier Adidas and pummer had concluded
an informal gentleman's agreement with
each other that neither company would
attempt to sign Pelle to a sponsorship
contract the so-called Pelle paack was a
recognition by both companies that
starting a bidding war over the world's
best footballer would be costly and
possibly disastrous for either of them
but before the World Cup Army dler
decided to break it instigating one of
sports most famous publicity stuns in
the process behind closed doors Puma had
signed Pelle for a huge at the time
$125,000 sponsorship deal to we pumers
at the World Cup and all competitions
going forward in order to get their
money's worth Puma asked Pelle to do
something all of us do every day without
thinking tie his shoes and that is
exactly what Pelle did just before the
start of the quarterfinal match between
Brazil and Peru Pelle asked the referee
to hold off on blowing the whistle so he
could bend down to rettie his shoes
right there in the middle of the field
allowing TV cameras broadcasting to the
entire world to zoom in and get a
close-up look at one of the greatest
players in the world lacing up his brand
new Puma cleats the ingenious stunt
worked out for Puma as it brought
increased recognition and sales to what
had been at that point a fairly small
Niche brand but it also outraged horse
dler and Adidas who felt they've been
played for fools the war was back on and
in Earnest the next year when boxers
mamed Ali and Joe Fraser squared off in
the so-called fight of the century
viewed by more than 300 million people
worldwide horse made sure that Adidas
was prominently featured signing an
endorsement deal with both fighters to
supply them both with Footwear during
the match horse had his own approach to
Sports Marketing that went beyond just
signing individual athletes and teams
however he envisioned corporate
sponsorship of entire sports federations
like FIFA and the ioc which would expand
the reach of his and his other brands
beyond the fans of a particular player
or team to fans of an entire sport hor
ended up starting his own sports
marketing company and established close
ties with the presence of both FIFA and
the ioc securing them lucrative
sponsorship deals with huge corporations
like Coca-Cola and McDonald's this made
lots of money for the sports Federation
but also works that well for Adidas 2
every World Cup since 1970 has been
supplied with match balls designed by
the three stripes the efforts to
commercialize the Olympics meanwhile
finally brought to an end the so-called
amateur era at the end of the 1980s
opening the door to professional
athletes and huge lucrative sponsorship
opportunities Andy and Rudy dasler were
bitter foes until the end of their lives
never reconciling you could even argue
the feud went beyond the grave as while
both of them were buried in the same
Cemetery in their Hometown and when they
died Rudy in 1974 and Addie in 1978 they
made sure to secure burial plots on
opposite sides of the cemetery as far
away from one another as it was
physically possible to be buried the war
between Adidas and pummer continued
after the deaths of the original
Brothers however as horse and Armen
duked it out with each other in the
1970s the rise of new popular sports
like jogging and Tennis spurred massive
growth in sports where sales lead to
huge bounds for both companies who
continue to focus not only on growing
their own brand but on defeating their
hated Eternal rivals in the 1980s the
Adidas Puma rivalry was on the verge of
destroying both companies you see
they've been so focused on each other
they failed to recognize the very
serious and potent threat posed by the
rise of American companies like Nik
rebok and this is one where I pronounce
it Nike I know some Americans pronounce
it Nike I'll use both interchangeably
for the rest of the video to annoy
everybody and these two companies were
especially popular in the United States
which just happened to be the largest
sportswar market on planet Earth the
problem soon became clear Adidas and
Puma long considered innovators in their
field had failed to get the times
neither company seemly understood the
needs and wants of modern consumers most
people that bought sneakers didn't
really care about their athletic prowess
how high performing they were they we
shoes that looked good and felt
comfortable to wear and that made them
look
cool yeah the I know these don't look
cool they made like a golf club they
also wanted to be able to buy their
shoes at their local department store or
Mall instead of a specialty Sporting
Goods store that had been the home of
Adidas and Puma for years not to mention
the internal structure of both companies
which were both still closed
family-owned businesses were out of set
with the modern day publicly traded
corporations by the end of the 1980s
Nike had become the world's number one
and it seemed like the two former Giants
of sportsware Might very well go the way
of the doo put it simply Adidas and Puma
had outgrown theas family and their
Petty Family
Feud today both Adidas and Puma are
large corporate entities with stock
offerings and open books like every
other big corporation on Earth the
remaining dlers were phased out of the
company's leadership as they were
gradually bought out and replaced with
professionals who had no personal stake
in the Rivalry that had dominated the
sportsware landscape for decades both
companies still have Global headquarters
in the hometown of the dlers though the
vast majority of shoe production is
conducted in far away countries with
lower labor costs the only Adidas or
Puma shoes still made in Germany are
Custom Design products specifically for
top athletes under sponsorship deals
which are written off as an advertising
expense and I believe to this day the
German national football team still
wears adid Das shoes when they play in
the World Cup and they have turned down
numerous buyout offers from larger
American companies because they want to
be seen wearing a German brand so
without the personal animosity of the
dlers the feud between Adidas and Puma
just sort of fizzled out the two
companies agreed to a formal truce in
2009 staging a charity football match
between their employees the first joint
activity between them since they were
founded all the way back in 1948 the
rift between the people of the town have
largely disappeared too it certainly
helps that NE addas or Puma is the
town's largest employer anymore both
companies are of course still rivals in
the marketplace though not any more so
than their Rivals with Nike or rebok
with Nike considered to be their biggest
rival as the largest Sports company on
Earth consigning Adidas and Puma to
second and third place respectively
however the legacy of the dler brothers
Feud continues to this day long after
the formal end of the so-called sneaker
Wars perhaps the biggest effect the two
companies had on the World of Sports is
the Pandora's Box that was opened by the
dlers in injecting huge amounts of
corporate money into sports which had
previously relied on ticket sales to
sustain themselves today major sports
federations are massive money-making
machines their star players command
massive exorian salaries and earn
Millions more in endorsement deals the
introduction of all this cash has led
some to question whether or not he taken
the fun or Spirit out of sports as well
as open the door to massive corruption
best seen by the series of scandals that
rocked FIFA and the world of football in
the 2010s it is amazing to think then
that a petty feud between two German
Brothers could have changed the entire
landscape of both Sports and business
but that's exactly what happened today
Adidas and Puma are Titans in both areas
but one has to wonder what might have
happened if Addy and Rudy dler have been
able to put their differenes aside and
continue working together as big as they
ended up separately could they have been
even greater have they just remembered
that blood is thicker than water it is
certainly an intriguing what if as well
as a cautionary tale though what the
moral of the story ultimately should be
we'll leave up to you so thank you for
tuning in to this episode of biographics
as note at the start of the video I've
been your host K Smallwood this video
was based on original article by Ben
Adelman links to their social can be
found below if they provided them and
just yeah if you enjoyed the video leave
a like um if you happen to have a
particular favorite oh oh a favorite
brand of sh you let us know in the
comments and if you want to see more
videos like this and me continue to make
a fool of myself as I settle into the
role of host subscribe and as always
like to say thank you to everyone for
watching and have the day you all
deserve